well let me tell you something the those
those law of attraction rules they've
changed
Aaron Doughty has the new rules there's
you're doing it wrong you're doing
awesome
hold on I meant to do this for the crowd
I meant to do this for the people I told
you I was gonna do this let me get set
up properly there we go no he didn't are
you brown nobody wants to you we got the
numbers numbers are in
wait wait wait cuz I'm about to take you
to coffee Zyliss cool okay oh it's
someone the filing you're in the wrong
universe what Marvel Comics got it all
twisty they got the multiverse wrong and
multiverse so what did the paper rock
your files gothic-style listen you do my
meditation bing bang i'll put you in the
right universe but that is just hey if
you're not ready for the money the
success they love the dating if you're
not ready for it don't do the meditation
[Music]
we're back life hey we're live welcome
back to the laughing Baba podcast
episode 2 what's up this time we're
talking about love a Miche yes the great
conqueror of all things and the
loving-kindness meditation the
loving-kindness meditation we're about
and we need a love revolution right now
what's happening we've got a lot for you
guys real quick a Miche as our I didn't
prepare you for this but would you like
to say a word about race
look I don't want to say okay I don't I
don't want to do comments on the unlike
the whole thing but I do want to do a
comment about some other people's
comments here listen outdoors if you're
selling your class hey you don't need to
do my thoughts on the shooting that
happened we don't need it I feel like
all of these grooves probably did it and
I just feel like hey if you're selling
of course can you leave it and honestly
is it mostly for ratings it's been
probably mostly for ready it's like this
is terrible scores fees that's why you
need to get your [ __ ] together make that
money join the class I got the webinar
starting in five minutes
wow that's super annoying I feel like
there's there's been uh let me say this
there's been so much pressure for
everyone to say anything that I feel
like a lot of very disingenuous people
have come out of the woodwork you know
what I mean I hear some people this like
like of course should you be aware of
what's going on around you of course
should you be engaged sure but if this
is not everyone's fight okay some people
like if you don't care don't pretend you
care I hate to say that but I see I see
these takes where they're just trying to
get attention dude they're just trying
to get attention hey if you don't mind
of course yeah don't lie and like don't
like time to sell your class to sell
your thing like to do a little hedge
wanna say it's not the right thing but
also 50% off because we care about the
people on this can't leave it just leave
it I I think um oh man we're so far off
track right now guys just so you know
our theme today we have a theme today
we've run off course we've heard your
comments okay we hear y'all's brutal
comments okay and we saw that y'all were
saying we're getting off track so that's
the last time we're gonna be up tracking
our thing we plan this and everything
and we opened off track I feel like it's
important to just address the topic
addresses you know otherwise people
gonna say why didn't you address it ah
okay there we addressed it we're here
we're here for the people we're here
we're doing our best baby and look if
you let me just say this if you
in protest be safe be smart I see a lot
of people they're running you know
they're getting I saw a guy he got his
his face like he can't see anymore cuz
he got rubber bullets in the face that's
the blue day the Baba's advice for free
safe let's but but let's get into it man
we got we had some pickup artists in
it's a lot of episode
it's a lot let's let's and that's what
we need right now as you said I'm a sh
so start us off what would you like to
talk about first man this new pickup
artist I don't know I found this new
pickup program started advertising to me
partly because you know I'm doing
research for the show okay I want to be
very clear but some people I get this
accusation it's like hey I found about
this pickup are doing oh hey hey are you
doing it
hey this got advertised to me okay and
you know what this guy's sales pitches
this guy's name's Jesse he's been in the
pickup artist game for years he had
another program um yet another company
called simple pickup where they just
hollowed out these girls on university
him into his two boys but now he's got a
new he's broke out on his own did he's
broken his own he's a new program called
endless options and a huge furnace sales
pitch is like basically like hey are you
brown nobody wants to [ __ ] you we got
the numbers numbers are in dude I saw
this article on [ __ ] BuzzFeed it's
he's not wrong let's give some cut let's
give some context to this because this I
saw this clip you dropped it in the in
the drive I saw this clip and I laughed
so hard because I was like what a hard
pitch this is like sales good you're
destined to be a loser so sign up with
me oh my gosh like he's got a black
backdrop and then here's the [ __ ] up
thing did you see the thing I put in
there I signed up for it I [ __ ] sign
up for it and what does he put well he
put up their offer has expired offer has
expired did you see it I didn't realize
that's what you were trying to say with
that so you signed up for this thing of
course of Court well obviously just for
the job he really sold me on like he
really sold me on the like hey if you're
brown it's almost like he's saying hey
if you're Brown don't worry about any
social justice [ __ ] you deserve this
nobody wants to [ __ ] you
hey they're racist the thing is he's not
wrong there's BuzzFeed did an article
about this and basically Asian men are
garbage in the section wait we'll wait
cuz I'm about to take you to coffee
Zyliss cool okay oh oh oh didn't expect
that did you I've been doing my own
research amnesia I don't sign okay of
course but I've been doing my own
research
let's introduce people to the the Guru
though this is my lookout fast just pay
attention now fast he gets to you're
implying that everyone's a loser who's
Asian this is messed up dude a little
racist okay let's go
the truth is Asian guys just have it
harder when it comes to dating this is a
study by Columbia University that
basically proves that Asian men have a
harder time other factors normalized an
Asian man would have to earn an
additional two hundred forty seven
thousand dollars to stand on equal
footing with his Caucasian counterpart
I'll never make it I'm fast-food I okay
I'm not making that money he did I'm an
artist I like to make jokes you know
Issus is this is this is a self-pity
porn this is hey you can't get get the
job done feel bad for yourself and
here's proof
here's scientific proof that you should
feel bad for your so it's not your fault
he's not your father University numbers
I saw there's a [ __ ] BuzzFeed they
did the study the under on the online
one so totally wrong it's time thank you
I'm so excited for this I freaking hate
how journalists interact with science
they have no idea they have no idea how
to read science because a lot of them
have never taken a math course in their
life you're doing God's work brother
you're doing your show the community how
brown men are not being impressed how AG
men are not be you tell us yes okay so
this is from this thing of racial
profiles in dating it's from this paper
okay so you have to go to the
actual study so okay I'm gonna look for
BuzzFeed now because why is BuzzFeed
putting up this [ __ ] then do they just
hear the crazy thing here's the crazy
thing they're all this is how journalism
works they all linked to each other
nobody actually does the research so
they go back to a New York Times article
and they were just rehashing what they
do they said and then I got to the
BuzzFeed article you saw by getting to
another like another link pulled me to
that so they're all just copying each
other's Oh misinterpretation it's it's
not just misinterpretation it's that
they're mischaracterizing is that fine
right and they're not explaining it in a
context that actually is the correct
context I'm so glad you said that and I
got to feel bad I'm a little guilty of
this myself because I think for like a
whole year I was doing a bit and I would
just be on stage in Toronto just saying
the numbers are in he gets off like
racist oh [ __ ] me then I didn't do that
but I was basically like spreading the
word on this for the first year I
thought when they said Asian they meant
like East Asian only so for the first
year I was telling them like you guys
[ __ ] man sorry might be because whatever
I don't know yeah I find out a year
later no I'm agent two Asian goes right
to Middle Eastern right and that's it no
so okay you're saying it's not true
though no no it's not true okay so it
comes from this paper first of all the
paper in like 2004
yeah 2007 okay so first of all it's
outdated okay okay this is this this is
back in the day but then they did a
speed-dating thing okay I mean should
they just set people in front of each
other and they go hey we're gonna find
out everything we need to about know
about you in like in five seconds decide
if you want to date this person yes or
no okay right and so then they'd say yes
no and then they crunch the numbers and
then they tried to draw conclusions so
you what you have to know about science
is that in science you have to publish
science and get it printed everywhere so
this press guy goes to the scientist and
says hey what's the craziest thing about
your study what's the craziest part so
the scientist is like hmm what are my
numbers say well if you all other things
being equal you know we could try to
match these numbers up numbers don't
work that way but okay let's just match
these numbers uh-oh $240,000 seven
thousand dollar difference between white
men and Asian men and the press guy
running he goes he goes aw dude I love
hey let me let me go send this to New
York Times let me send it to the New
York Times then some idiot journalist
goes hey that's an interesting study
people are gonna click on that and then
they perpetuate a like this feeling of
I'll never have a chance to all these
Asian men who go hey how much do you
make I make one dollar an hour oh damn
it I've got to make two hundred and
forty eight thousand dollars an hour
I'll never make it it's just like no I
don't over [ __ ] me on the face of it
okay first of all just science doesn't
work that way where you could discover a
fact like that like it studies me what
they mean in a very specific context and
the numbers aren't clear and you can't
just extrapolate statistics or whatever
but let's just lead with that fact okay
but cuz let me show you something you
probably didn't realize so one of the
findings of the study is just that
people tend to not date interracially in
general okay this is the fact of life
and the brown people worst with that I
just wanna say I join a full disclosure
for go ahead so listen to this look for
equal success with an African what
African American woman a Hispanic needs
to earn a man needs to earn an extra one
hundred eighty four thousand dollars a
year a white man needs to earn an extra
two hundred twenty thousand dollars so
it's just like it's just like all
they're trying to other really saying is
that people don't like to date outside
their race which is kind of a weird
thing to say anyway and I was like it's
kind of a weird study to begin with that
they'd be citing but also but also those
numbers don't mean what they mean
because it's in a speed-dating context
speed dating isn't like a relationship
thing it's like a first first
impressions bare minimum like nothing
it's a nothing burger so it's like yeah
these people this guy has taken one tiny
number decontextualized it from the
study which shows that everybody like
you can fudge the numbers any way you
want to say that hey you need to earn an
extra blah blah blah to date outside of
your race and then he's basically said
okay you Asian people you guys can't
date anybody so come join my course
where I teach you how to do it right
right he just takes a little thing and
just runs with it ya know the science is
always [ __ ] with these guys and
tries to pretend that like that's the
thing he's vicious man his sales video
it's so tight oh gosh
but this guy okay so so you when you
looked into this is it the same fur
because I did hear that it was asian men
and african-american women see the worst
numbers is it true for african-american
women - you're saying that's just just
economically judging this doesn't make
sense I mean it's just a bad way to do
stats it's a meaningless study also also
just think about what it means and and
understand that the the they're just
trying to do like this correlation of
variables multi variables and trying to
like push numbers around but that's not
how it works so it's not true that if
you go to a like a white woman and say
hey you can either have this white guy
who makes zero dollars an hour or you
can have this this uh this guy simply
makes 70k a year and she'd go oh I'm
going with the white guy cuz the Asian
guy doesn't make two hundred forty seven
thousand dollars a year like it's just
not out remember when I started dating
on Simpsons who know he was killing it
they all these all the women in science
Simpsons like the regular like in
Milhouse's mom all these women were like
cuz he was gonna go get arranged
marriage but all these women on there
they were like okay he has a degree he's
a Bachelor of Science degree he owns
this convenience store and then he got a
Ferrari for the episodes like come on
lady like it was great episode people do
a rocking and rolling and like you know
what it's very negative thinking man I
know it's true man I've told guys for
years like don't think there's any kind
of Asian issue nobody wants to [ __ ] you
just cuz of you it's not race hey st.
you and like people internalize this
inner I didn't know I'd be given of self
talk self confidence like but people
internalize a negative self confidence
from like numbers whatever and then they
actually become like the losers that
nobody wants to mess around with because
they've internalized it yeah and that
thing and they go that's the problem
within cells they go oh you guys just
I'm just
you guys nobody's gonna have sex with me
and then all the girls go yeah I don't
have a sex with a guy that says I don't
want to have sex with them yeah no no
it's your oh you're just killing your
own self confidence well you gotta
remember is that like basically nobody
wants to [ __ ] you until one person wants
to [ __ ] you like just every couple of
months someone will want to
but the general answer is gonna be no
and there sooner you realize that as a
guide the happier you'll be
you're not it's not about you baby
especially if you're 21 years old nobody
wants to [ __ ] you honestly they're
[ __ ] like thirty year olds half the
time like they're the girls I mean or
like you know whatever it is that the
dating market stuff these guys are
playing on an insecurity it's it's it's
and he is a sociopath right like we're
talking this guy's making so much money
I feel like yeah and what are they gonna
tell you they're gonna tell you exactly
what I'm gonna tell you but only after
tearing down your self-confidence
they're gonna tell you hey you were a
loser because of your race which is such
garbage racist stuff anyways and then
they're gonna say but only with me can
you achieve self-confidence no you could
have just achieved self-confidence on
your own and saved yourself money baby
come on come on man and they are
attacking the Asian community this is
great that we called this out the zoo
rape have you seen a pickup artists
seminar it's all [ __ ] brown the
volunteers I was brown it's always like
a meek sweet Indian kid I don't know how
you got suckered into it and they always
sunjai come on up here man [ __ ] let's
rock and roll bro let's do it and it's
like dude can you not put this guy's
face on TV he's an engineer somewhere
he's gonna get fired like the only thing
the only reason that guy doesn't get
like me to it is cuz they everyone pass
around the office and said hey he's
really lonely can we just leave it it's
just you sad you can't
it's like mean right from work and be
like excuse me Sanjay I didn't know I
really didn't know that there was like
an a higher number of Asian men in the
pickup artist game like Asian and video
there's I see a lot of Brown and Asian
guys but maybe I'm I feel like the real
thing is just people with knows like
social skills what you might commonly
refer to as social skills like like if
you can if you can go here's the deal if
you can get in the game
you're fine moat the one people who
can't get help or the people who can't
get in the game and that's a problem you
know if you can't go say hi to somebody
if you can't hold a basic conversation
that's a problem
if you can get in the game baby then
it's a matter of finding someone you
click with dude you're not gonna quit
until you click with someone and you do
have to go with confidence if you are
going on with that insel vibe probably
like I will literally get with anybody
who like would be willing to give me
their body I can do it dude have you
seen the girlfriend activation code I
got that's another one future topic
there's a guy who has a video called the
girlfriend activation code it's putting
the girl's brain is just like a computer
dude these thank you
they're so sexist they're so like this
like now I'm realizing some of the stuff
is racist it's like built on racist
stereotypes this is just terrible it's
brutal man have you seen they're
sociopaths Scott Jack losing so much
money too because every I click on all
the ads I always took on the ad I always
goddamn click on the ad cuz [ __ ] him
especially since we start doing the show
I'm like funny you know what it's my job
now I'm clicking on the ad it's like
part of my work they're getting [ __ ]
but this guy he put up a video with like
he picked up like a 20 year old girl and
this is where a lot of them say like hey
it's okay because they blur out the face
doesn't matter
so okay like and and you know one of the
commenters talked about Julien Blanc
from company called real social dynamics
he's advertising to me it's like hey are
you having trouble with confidence and
you need to get in there like he's
teaching guys how to get out there big
part of the program is though like
you're you can't do this on your own you
need help but the thing I want to say
they are sociopaths in the sense that
like they're going and picking up girls
okay they're saying like hey as long as
you blur it out there's a small
percentage that like they don't blur it
out they don't blow out the girl but but
there's they have this thing the whole
industry is free this is pretty vicious
it's called their column in fields like
an army guy and the in field is I got I
hire a guy to videotape me picking up
girls on the street these guys are like
hey I need proof you can't just sell a
pickup artist course dude
you need infi they call it infield
footage this guy RSD julian hits
he's he's a king did he's got 500 hours
of him on the internet just getting at
girls dude and he got he actually got
cancelled a couple of years ago cuz he
was in Japan and he's like hey these
Japanese girls they're so submissive and
he just grabs a girl's head and just
pushes down his crotch and says come
[ __ ] them through white like he's like
say [ __ ] like that
he got cancelled the the I want to say
the Scott jag guy I saw an ad with him
dude he had a 20 year old girl in bed
with him didn't blow her out she's in
the ad she he like like were there in
[ __ ] bed he just wakes I was like hey
guys just puts together hey guys it's
like the Ferrari that the Tai Lopez
right he's like dude that's no that's
crazy
she's just sitting there smiling and
she's in an ad for this guy's pickup
artists video come on dude you didn't
even ask also also is the girl really
random and did he really sleep there
like I I'm skeptical to the point where
okay I don't even believe ya they just
pay him dude think about how easy that
is
look look listen think about it this way
first of all you can guarantee the girl
will be like smoking hot
if they don't really have to sleep with
you and you just hire them then you can
guarantee it's gonna go exactly the way
you want okay then you can guarantee you
stage it the right way you'd have to
worry about them getting seeing you on
Kate like filming them right this is
like accusation this could destroy the
whole pickup artists community this guy
a hooman TV crewman TV he faked being on
Ellen okay
every day I've seen so many of your
videos what he does these videos where
like the thumbnail is some hot girl in
like a thong and right where he goes up
to him goes hey baby like you want to be
with me and he's like next to a bad car
and the girl always goes no I would
never move someone like you and he goes
all too bad and he walks over like the
Ferrari next to him without a frame and
then the girl goes cool wait whoa what's
your name and like oh come on he's like
it's like so obviously fake and but he
does all these things to try to pretend
they're real like he'll blur out their
face like he'll like which is which is
like makes it seem like oh yeah I can't
who they are whatever and it's the
blurred out face could be actors yeah
that's true well and that's next level
to cuz you can't even look up who they
are because they're right so so uh
everything goes according to plan it's
all staged that's the highest level of
like so obviously fake right of course
it's fake but all these kids are like
watching this going wool like all I need
is like a car like to that's that's what
you do there's there's and there's even
that kissing prey the kissing pranks
guys that guy he's got yes Frank
invasion he's like yeah dude hey hey hey
man hey lady you wanna you wanna rock
paper scissors for a kiss and then the
girl always goes like yeah and he always
wins and then he like does it just kiss
him he like forceful he's like he's like
grabbing their butt and like he's an
extra lips sound on it he's like hey
guys check this out this is how you do
it he's got a pervert level if you dude
it's let's have let's do this lesson
you're in love you're even a just you do
a squeeze this guy's doing [ __ ] he's
fingering people on the street in from
the kid there's always kids but here's
here's a crazy thing dude he had like he
realized that he would get views if he
would do like crazy additions to his
videos so he had this he had this thing
where do you take it you gotta take it
no no check it out he goes mommy makeout
day yes mom's but then one of his videos
was making out with my actual mother I
[Laughter]
mean he says he did and then later got
you guys that wasn't my real mom
right on you break so you then was like
it's like we it's like a weird level
like I did should this be on YouTube
anymore like this is getting strange no
but okay I feel like that is like a
small microcosm of what pickup artistry
is kind of is it's a lot of faking it to
make yourself seem because okay as the
guru you have to be this guy that
everyone desires all the time yes and
when you're out showing people you don't
actually have to demonstrate your skills
you have to show them in your videos
which are highly edited subject to all
these abilities to trick people yeah
look the the big selling point are in
front of these Julien Blanc though and
obviously I'm an idiot so I'm just
believing this guy's work for it but one
of the things that he does is he'll just
assign you a wingman that will keep
hollering at girls until someone wants
to [ __ ] you some of them just make that
guarantee they're like it's $5,000 for
the weekend dude I in there like I will
hold your hand I will take your old
spots hold your hand let's [ __ ] you
that's hilarious
look guys look guys if you're out there
and you're struggling you go Steven you
make it sound you you know it's it's not
that easy whatever you've been out of
the game obviously I'm married so I'm
not in the pickup scene at all you don't
know what it's like okay guys let me
tell you this there are really two
things from the pickup artistry
community you can probably take and
leave everything else one that's good is
confidence and two is that if you're if
you have to get laid I'm not even saying
that should be a big wat desire of yours
but it's a numbers game it's like sales
there's some magical words you're gonna
say that's gonna force you into two
sales no the first thing you learn in
sales is the sales as a numbers game
it's not an objectification thing it's
not saying that like okay just good as
many girls you can't like it's not like
that but it is a matter of like don't
get hung up if someone's not into you
little long like oh there's a lot of
that to people get stuck and friendzone
[ __ ] or like get obsessed with someone
and it's like hey man yes someone loves
you someone hot loves you just as the
loser that you are not her but someone
else does or you know someone else I've
always said there's a big market of tens
who love sixes you got to keep it moving
though
you're not have you seen this thing of
like when is the Lord is abundant the
Lord is a bunt oh gosh it's like hold on
let me find out let me find it you find
it I'm gonna say Nithyananda I feel like
we can we can Oh Oh hold on hold on let
me say that let me say this let me say
this real quick see to your point about
there's someone for everybody yes I
totally believe in that and it's like
this should this show TLC release this
show called hot dude have you seen this
because these guys who are obsessed with
big women like they want Israel they
want they want their women to be fat and
like that's just what it is and it's a
god is great these like these like guys
who are good-looking dudes are with
these like 350 pound women and that's
just what it is and they love it and
they love it and it's like and I see
that I don't judge the guy I go hey
that's great somebody found their match
and that's fine that's fine man someone
loves you just the way you are you know
there's people out there personality
goes a long way you know your each other
the most high universal source baby
dudes personality is everything gets
told people pull off crazy numbers yeah
that you get hung up on these like
arbitrary stats I'm not tall enough I'm
not confident enough I'm not this and if
I'm not that enough to just learn to
work with what you got there's so many
things you can't change
ya gotta you gotta find love where you
can man I'm glad I I locked it down when
I did because I look at some of my
friends it's a waste landed it in a way
I don't think I don't like I said I
think you have an even playing field
with every other guy if you just have
confidence if you're just a personable
guy but at the same time it's kind of
hard to find people if you don't want to
do the data caps if you want to do the
dating apps it's never been easier if
you don't want to just do the swipe
swipe swipe swipe it's hard it's a grind
man I mean people yeah it's a great
thing to do and it's so it put some work
into it we're also a little bit weird
and lazy about it it's like Oh what we
talk about like oh it's so much work
what's work man you gotta go dancing
Cody head sing brother I you know
sucking him like a family friend of ours
he bet he's like
kind of in a friend zone with this girl
and then she and then I think she
married a guy or something I don't know
moves home whatever six months later
he's sending me stefan molyneux videos
about how feminism destroyed Rome and I
said baby can you get out of the house
though
hey let's go talk to someone before you
send me the [ __ ] feminism is
destroying the call like can we go out
that's my favorite thing ever
he said he sent you stefan molyneux
videos he sent me a stefan molyneux
feminism destroyed Rome and he's like
not an Amish I mean it's impossible that
they won't have sex with us feminine
because feminism now they won't have sex
with us we're [ __ ]
dude is we got a revolt how community
dude dude there there that's it that's a
Ravenel you go down to now they have
okay so then then you got the red bit
this is complicated we might have to
draw a chart we math we need a I I've
long thought we need to chart we might
neuter cuz 21 conventions is around
there yeah treatment committees you got
our SD you got like you got straight up
pick up
you got a sociopath pick up you got men
and then you got men's development over
here means development there's some
legitimate men's development by the way
I don't want to say that everything in
divest men's development is a scam
obviously there's some good apples bad
apples everywhere let me I think some
girls are even maybe out there saying
hey I'm glad like there might be win the
guy who there like this guy was I see
pictures he was a loser loser any Linda
same rooming guy you know teaching men's
fashion teaching look if your parents
don't teach you how to be hygienic if
they don't teach you to go out and you
know be sociable if they don't teach you
how to go get a drink and maybe dance or
you know do you don't have to do that
but that's it's helps you know what I
mean yeah yeah so it may be you need
somebody to teach you but probably not
maybe you can figure it out baby get
some friends but have you heard have you
seen some of Aaron Doughty's techniques
ok now you're throwing me a curveball
dude who's Aaron okay no you're I turn
myself on this guy because remember I
was telling you last time you got those
guys that are like and they're in our
comment section by the way they're in
the comments of doing hey man great glad
will you do what you're doing
glad you call up the people you do I go
to their bio it says hey course King
crypto King Forex King six months to six
figures I'll teach you the whole [ __ ]
he's got it okay Aaron Doughty is that
of the meditation game okay so if you
want to know parallel universe
meditation he's got that crystal healing
Law of Attraction 11 left rear a funny
odd purana again is he the repeated
ananda nithyananda is also like him just
ripping these scientology bits Landmark
Education dude Nithyananda in his
speeches he's like Landmark Education
teachers they stole it from the Hindus
would you would you call this guy like
this this Aaron Doughty guy cuz on the
theme of love he teaches people like you
sent me he's got like a relationship
meditation or something where you
supposedly attract your relationship you
know if you just listen to his thing
it's it's beautiful man and it gets a
little hard on the clickbait and I think
I put in a thumbnail for your boy Sri
master sri a Gardena master street
instantly attract Law of Attraction
three ways to attract a specific person
instantly all caps into your life Law of
Attraction this Aaron Doughty this guy
Aaron Doughty I'll say this genuine guy
learns all the meditations he's always
taking new classes always taking new
courses you know I'm saying yeah here we
go sighs one of his hitters here's one
of his hitters dude look at these views
I I didn't change my game dude dude and
I think the top one and I think I found
my new niche to as the laughing Baba
I think these I want to start doing
meditations for single girls
and bring it in eel the energy side of
your heart
can this get to the point I'm he's [ __ ]
shree shree Aaron bhava dirty I did that
I ain't doing jack for you did hey boys
fer my boat before my boys out there
dude law of attraction bring them in
star children even star children are do
you know a lightworkers are no note he
does it all he's the game usually drives
me crazy about the stuff like I don't
believe that this guy believes it
no he believes it no - well he went to a
class here's the thing okay well let me
let me compare it to somebody I have
research which is Shree Aakash Rana
whatever his guys okay cuz he did a
time-travel meditation and part of this
thing was like his thing was like does
this work I don't know maybe it works
maybe it does it maybe it doesn't work
maybe it does but this is very
complicated that other you know he
didn't even believe it's so obvious
during the thing that this guy does not
believe in this thing but he wants to
make a video about it because he knows
it's gonna get views because anything
gets fused one of his big videos is like
meditate to make your your crush text
you back how stupid you me dude
Houston okay that's just stupid can we
agree that's one thing about can I say
one thing in defense of my brain I love
talking he did because you like half you
know you're kind of like like he is
Aaron he believes it he's just a sweet
little dumb dumb dude look you look into
his doughy big eye he's like so what's
happening he has that slow talk he's not
a Baba Ram Dass of it he's automatic on
level but he does believe it let me [ __ ]
lipid keep talking I'm just gonna show
everyone that the doughy eyes you know
just that's that's what this guy looks
like he does have some hypnotizing eyes
there he's beautiful man he's beautiful
guy he believes it although he does and
we're talking like 510 meditations each
I did the parallel universe meditation I
did his parallel universe meditation and
universe well did I I don't know I told
you how it works but basically he's
he says it look look if you're having
trouble in life your things aren't going
the way you want in your life
hey I got a meditation for you you do
them at it you might be in the wrong
minute you might be in the wrong
universe that might be the issue things
aren't going well for you not your fault
you're the wrong universe simple
mistakes it will mix up it's it's the
self-pity porn thing again your fault
it's someone [ __ ] up the filing you're
in the wrong universe no Marvel Comics
got it all twisted they got the
multiverse wrong
someone did the paper where are your
files Gothic style
bing bang I'll put you in the right
universe but then he says hey if you're
not ready for the money the success the
love the dating if you're not ready for
it
I look eight listen let me tell you I
love these people they always do that
it's like it's it's the old viagra trick
I'm like hey dude this warning this
could make you rock hard for four hours
two boys be careful if you're not ready
for you to be rock hard for four hours
don't take this medication if you're not
ready to have tons of well women to be
all over you yeah it's a very powerful
very very careful dude this could bring
you tons of wealth and success be
cautious about giving me money dude I
know law of attraction well let me tell
you something the those those law of
attraction rules they've changed
Aaron Doty has the new rules there's
you're doing it wrong you're doing
awesome
hold on I meant to do this for the crowd
I meant to do this for the people I told
you I was gonna do this let me get set
up properly there we go and wow dude
always I mean yeah I told you I'd get a
nice chair unfortunately zooms really
bad at tracking my body dude I like that
he has two demons by side and nityananda
is a [ __ ] sex God you know what I'm
saying
you see a sex scandal
whoa look at that face am I technically
sitting in his lap I feel uncomfortable
now dude I he'll hit it he doesn't give
a [ __ ] boy wait I didn't want to talk
about Nityananda I wanted to talk this
is what we do we get off track let's
stay on track here I'm gonna stop
distracting you with this chick Aaron
Jodi I just wanted to show you my new
chair dude but but yeah look Aaron dowdy
just to wrap up with him first of all I
think you turned me on to a new
meditation niche that I could get into
which is guided meditation for single
girls just feel better you know hey hey
the fact that you're alive you're a
miracle so what if you're six hey don't
worry about that God loves you I'm gonna
love you you're a child of the Most High
Universal source and if you do it with
some of that music and you know yeah
it's a lot of it's the music it's the
music yeah yeah dude he is he's a sexy
man he is in the look I'm saying this
for Aaron Doughty his courses are like
20 bucks he's not crazy he just goes to
it he does win it crystal healing
believes in it what do you do some
people believe in it but but how can it
look like have something to believe in
sure but don't believe in all of it at
least she thank you one thing that
you're gonna believe in kind of you're
gonna suspend disbelief for anything
yeah you realized that you know whatever
I do find it weird and like look and I
mentioned this about the nithya Ananda
she's got real quick-like
she's she's over here in Canada and this
is why people hate multiculturalism
she's here in Canada she's Catholic she
says she says nothing's good enough here
I gotta go to an ET Ananda
why would you I'm gonna I'm gonna hold
you accountable right now I'm holding
you accountable they're putting a stop
to this this this fish galloping right
now
listen you topi that Erin daddy had the
new secrets to the secret tell me the
new secrets planes
oh oh dude oh like I mean who has time
to listen to this [ __ ] it's nonsense
I come on it's in the thumbnail look
it's his thumbnails are him going like
this big blue eyes he's like no
then it says here law of attraction
changed listen now Mercury retrograde is
[ __ ] up whatever it that's just his
that's his this is YouTube game that's
amazing
that's how he sells it now to be honest
I I didn't go through that one now I did
hear him talk about going to a bashar
seminar and i can tell you this but star
is someone that we gotta look into look
at this it will come to you it's time to
no no do this every day
okay days yeah I see your point star
sees a relatable view on star seats just
below there and look at what's behind
him there's like a blue angel lady right
okay he believes in that really he
believes in that parallel universe
meditation he believes it I just did she
really or is he like Sri Aakash Rana
who's sort of like I don't know maybe I
mean if you guys want it yes maestro not
full of [ __ ] if you guys really want to
you know [ __ ] Erin dowdy I think the
biggest clue for me for Erin Doughty is
that he's going to other scams dude it's
like when I called the guy the the the
Pihl company selling toys to my dad I
call those customer service she's like
hey hey hey this is what coffee Zilla
will do to you did I yeah I realized I
can ruin people for people
so let's ruin you Erin daddy for you
right now three things you agree to
before you our very special guest you
probably see him already
especially Las Vegas so that we can get
this insight actually understand the
things that you have those are things
that you forgot this is what you said
right yes like people for God why are
they actually in this world
look at these two hucksters right here
to selling people I'm gonna say it again
one huckster we're watching one guy's
semi getting scammed himself all right
yeah doubt he paid him I mean this is
the kind of social uh that master
serious and what a great guy Aaron is I
here's being him $5,000 can he do a
collab with you he's people well anyway
maybe I shouldn't throw Aaron under the
bus maybe maybe you know but honestly
probably let's be real he goes to like
look whatever money he's making he has
one course $40 yep
and whatever money he's making dude he's
spending more money on courses cuz every
other video he's talking about oh i went
to the bashar course it was only three
thousand dollars but he let my friend
come too okay so first we did a very
powerful meditation on that it's like
hey how can you go to all of them heat I
agree with you don't believe in all of
them it's too much you know it's to do
all of them it's like hey just leave it
I used to be but this reminds me of even
the the recruiter for Nityananda can you
imagine hey hey
I'm fact-checking you again this is what
I this is what I do this is why I'm here
you're gonna bring me all the garbage
and I'm gonna separate together dude
what did you find about Bush are ya
there's no not Bashar I found this about
this Aaron Doughty guy Oh God
you're all over right now this guy okay
first of all this course wouldn't hurt a
fly first of all listen listen first of
all I have no idea of that there's an
upsell after this but first the first
thing this is called the shift Academy
its $67 okay $67 not bad that's a tight
lopez number and then sixty-seven
dollars a month
aka 700 dollars a year
hey Aaron I've caught listen listen
maybe the monthly you're changing my
mind is the last time I checked he had a
$40 morning accelerator of course we're
25 videos that's a fair value I'm sorry
dude
burning accelerator he's gonna give you
a little guided meditation for you he's
waking you up in the morning there's
value there that's $40 you guys I'm
willing I'm okay with it
67 a month it were chartered this is a
lot let me tell you what I like I like
that you I don't want you to lose sort
of your innocence innocence dude I love
it I want you to keep taking these
courses of course I don't want you to
get like me all jaded I
I see these people and I'm immediately
like oh dude I've I took a quart arted
of course this week I started of course
this week this guy but let me tell you
something this guy hundred thousand
followers a hundred and forty thousand
subscribers on YouTube also has a
podcast I said you know what it's an
investment that's not going back about
the podcast he has not gonna bother get
back with a podcast who'd you buy who'd
you buy Michael Sandler I love animation
I want to hear how you I really want you
to go through these try them out
seriously I know you will and then
report back to us and tell us what you
think I want to get know I should be
graduated I should have my degree next
week all right two weeks
Oh am I gonna agree not to take us off
track here
and I want to get us back on track and
that will take you let's get back on
track
hey I want to tell you about this secret
how do I say it in a way that all of a
sudden all the pickup guys will listen
up a way to make any girl fall
hopelessly in love with you whoa dude
how about that how it how about that
back not by me I'm not a am i saying yet
no the Better Business Bureau is saying
that that these what I'm about to show
you guys so powerful yeah that women
were falling hopelessly in love with
people and sending them all their money
from across the seas in the form of
Western Union payments guys we're about
to take a rabbit hole and this might
take the rest of the episode I have no
idea this is hard it's hot here's the
deal what I'm about to show you our
verified romance scripts that romance
scammers used and the BBB published them
Better Business Bureau publish them and
they were used over and over the same
scripts and they were they were like
trimmed down you know to make women fall
in love these white women they'd post
these like military photos I was like
hot like hot guys and then they'd send
them the same emails every time and then
they'd call them and talk to them and
they had like excuses for why they had
accents and this is a rabbit hole there
this is a rabbit hole that we need to go
down because if you're hopeless and you
say
hey I can't make anyone fall in love
with me with my personality just try out
a Roman script baby do it let's go let's
do Roman be honest dude these literally
get girls so bad there's videos these
women going hey I know I got scammed and
they found the guy and he's in Nigeria
but I think that the real guy's gonna
show up they can't even get their mind
around the fact they've been scammed
they're in denial that isn't saying dude
left scripts what's the script I wanna
do check this out okay so the first
thing you need to know is so this guy
went to jail for 27 years for scamming
all these women he scammed over a
million dollars over a million dollars
you are paying for your women your
women's meal this guy had them pay him a
million dollars and he never did
anything for him think about that okay
check this out
so he has formats so you you start with
the dating site and if so he's got
different like categories for Anaheim
yet all team one if you're the first to
email her send this
wow you spark up my thinking for faculty
and you'll notice it's sort of broken
English and not even that convincing
which I have a theory I have a theory
about this but I'll tell you in a second
I am ready I am ready to stop searching
and who knows the roasted my heart could
be yours Lowell drop a note email
address and I'll reply instantly just
you wish to email to my email has been
Johnson six six ninety at gmail.com you
on my mom hey Ben Johnson okay let's go
a couple of couple of lessons that we
can learn there okay first of all don't
trust a six six ninety like what's
what's this email if someone's gonna do
a underscore backslash default backs
like back it's like those Instagram
channels are like underscore backup
channel backup channel hey leave it
come on Ben Johnson sixty-six ninety
it's just it's shady its Shady okay the
other thing though I like the big words
I like the sophistication it remind this
is such it's it's so a migrant dude I
have I have cousin they come I remember
we went out my cousin were out with him
at getting food
french fries went over the bowl and he
goes these french fries are over
capacity but he meant it wow you spark
up my entire thinking is why yes it's
what they want to hear and also like
there's so much there like so many hooks
that you don't see like I'm ready to
stop searching I don't want to play
games right you my heart could be yours
I'm open people okay so then let's move
on my heart Kabir's lol lol if she has a
lovely profile brah but but no pic
honestly very lovely profile and I wish
I could see your picture there's a
feeling that tells me you're beautiful
though though what matters is the
internal beauty that hook set the hook
I'm not like the other guys kindly send
me one too big big golden bin yes their
name their count okay but but here's the
thing
they don't actually care if you're
pretty or not they want to be it's the
connection that getting the photo makes
cuz they'll never see they don't care
but the fact that you send them a
picture makes gets the hook I've sent
you something there's studies that say
if someone does something for you
they're more likely to feel like they're
connected to you okay no that's how
that's that's a sociopath move actually
yeah I could be one of these hard pickup
artists if you want someone like you
don't do [ __ ] for them every time they
do something for you they feel like they
love you more 100% if she sends you a
wink hello my hunch okay so that uh so
this is sort of the longer thing I love
family a lot the wise say if you can't
fly run if you can't run walk if you
can't walk run but all means keep moving
seems the best thing in my world and
that's why I never looked back
he's hardworking of course lovely woman
that will follow me in my dreamland it's
a natural thing from God himself hope to
hear from you ASAP okay another thing
they play on religion a lot all about
they're all about I'm a god-fearing man
and I'm ready and one thing that also
sort of signals to people is oh you
wouldn't play around with that you're
not a scam because you wouldn't
you would yeah yeah you're mentioning
God is a good move did he say strong
play strong play God God is great that's
if she's complaining about distance look
they've already got it
Wow do you know this is they teach sales
they call it actually objection handling
do anything for scam these nails it I do
believe it's early to discuss distance
wherever I find my true love I will live
from the rest of my life that uh one
woman man I mean like if she replies
doesn't give your email so okay so
here's the thing so right away
it's all about the first step of the the
scam is it's all about first making them
feel like you're super interested in
them then getting a picture and they're
like they're real email and then you
start emailing them so now you're off
the dating site and then you get their
phone number the big thing is their
phone number and say hold on let me see
if I can find it and once they get that
number I think you're on a database of
like lonely people that we could take
advantage of because nook it will keep
calling you man so so here's the thing a
lot of these guys are from Nigeria and
that's I'm not trying to be like I'm not
trying to stereotype there everyone
knows it's big in the game they're big
in that game it's fine yeah and and like
they even have a word for um they're
called what do they call it I think
Yahoo boys yeah yeah Yahoo boys they
carry out fraud all the time like
basically love fraud love it's a
specific type of fraud I think that's I
think that's what they call it I might
be wrong people might correct me but
anyway check this out so then they're
gonna get on the phone with you but they
have a Nigerian accent that's why I
brought it up so they have this accent
how how do you explain that away cuz
you're supposedly you know you're just a
rake bin Johnson why does Ben Johnson
have a Nigerian accent well check out
big golden band look at this look at
this look at this if you have a French
kiss I bet I would you'd be happy to
know I have a French background
oh he's foreign but sophisticated for it
English is my second language so I have
an accent
all my so then you go
Oh Jackson he also said my life has been
a story of love now I think we should
really take this to another level let me
hear the voice of an angel be warned I
have an unsorted accent but sexy mole so
you prepare them for hey I'm gonna have
a weird accent yeah yeah what is that is
this some kind of data mining operation
and then they just kind of give the
numbers to some guy it's like what is
that like why wouldn't he just say I
have a French accent we're done I guess
because I've heard that they have like
fishing departments and then they have
the calling Department so it's almost
like it goes from here goes to a call
center call centers just getting leads
all day I'm like okay they do have like
Nigerian guys I think it's because look
if you gave it like dim the idea that oh
it's some accent that you maybe not
don't know so well they'll just
associate an unknown accent Americans
are famously bad with accents so no idea
sexy so it's fine as long as it's not
and hey maybe we might find the numbers
are just for that but Holy Spirit you
hear that by the way did she tell you
that your accent yeah I like your accent
dude I think it's good that's how bad I
am with accents I don't know like
literally literally you said I had no
literally in my mind you have an accent
I don't even know what kind it is but
knowing that you're Indian I would guess
oh yeah he's got an Indian ish accent I
like it good I like that you're you
you're kind of saying like hey man don't
[ __ ] listen that Jessie you're
beautiful baby that's all I'm saying
listen but check but check this out so
go big golden bin he's got your email he
wants to hear the voice of an angel but
check out what he's saying in this chat
before he's heard the voice of this girl
look this stand in front of a pastor and
have him pronounce us husband and wife
wow dude so miss Hattie's money this guy
needs so much money so quick like you
gotta just watch that yep yep and where
does it it start so slowly
it starts talking about money right
search money you can see it appear more
and more often in the search bar and the
search thing and like down here it's all
about money
such a science dude so there's really
five Jenny Mills in these are like
emails yeah yes several emails in and
calls in so first no money no mention of
money and that's where how they lower
people's card is because people think
it's all about money so you're gonna ask
me about money no no first they get your
email then they get your number then
they start talking you for months
they'll talk to you for months before
and they make you fall in love with them
like legitimately fall in love with them
you talked to eat like you will not talk
but you hear the stories of these women
who've gotten scammed or men they were
legitimately they think they're in love
with these people then they say hey I've
got this small thing that needs to be
taken care of I don't have money I have
tons of money but I don't have money for
a second yeah but they get quick they
get the trip wire product it's called
trip wire because it's like low-hanging
just to see if you'll buy right see if
you buy it some people never spend and
they don't want to waste their time
right so and it also gets you in the
door like you're more likely to give
them a two thousand dollars if you've
given them five dollars like famous
psychology yeah yeah so they get you to
spend like seventy bucks on some bogus
excuse right and slowly they just
Ratchet it up by the end of this thing
they're signing off because I can try
they take your hopes and dreams for love
and they say hey I can make some money
on that check out the sign up this is in
the middle this is in the middle good
read that send me oh wait
we'll write more later today your
husband then they're saying your husband
dude but they're like they're already
married look I love you were married
it's like psychological game stirred
yeah man what a cute game we just call
each other he just calls me her sister's
I'm his wife
cuz he loves me dude that's how do you
live with yourself on those my buddies
so we're gonna call Center in Montreal
and he so he did a lot of these like
make like older women fall in love but
then he did a lot of seniors he said at
one point they went writing the seniors
and for the seniors they had
to play like this grandson game they had
to do the same thing call all the time I
just love talking to you and then they
sort of had to go and it's like I just
have a bit of a money problem and I
don't know what I'm gonna do
they just do this thing I don't know
what I'm gonna do okay can you can you
send me $200 like yeah they do this they
start with this moment it's insane man
it's insane and like okay so towards the
end I just gotta shave it I got to show
you the whole arc okay show me show me
isn't this so fast I think when I saw
this I was like I was like my mind was
blown at the architecture
this is thought out sometimes people are
working so hard on their scam that I'm
like hey just get a job are you [ __ ]
this is very unstable man this what I
mean like the guys doing the scam there
I think 80 percent of time not making
money all included they're wild they're
emotional they stay waste money like
this I heard a podcast about a guy who
did this scam but more in-depth was like
for women and he like we're talking
about the documentary showed him sucking
them dry we're talking about like you
don't love me anymore you know [ __ ]
care if you care documentary - it's
great but yeah dude at some point you
just go hey just get a job dad get a job
baby
yeah no no dude so after I said they
guys start getting money they get the
trip wire then look at how these
payments are set up it's so convoluted I
want you to know I love you with all my
life and I appreciate all you have done
for me and I promise to pay you back all
your money and start a new life with you
in a short while I can only wish the
door company accepts the 8500 or you
would or would you be able to send me
815 hundred dollars today because he's
like some construction guy to make it
ten thousand so I could at least beg the
door company with that and promise them
I will spend the send the remaining four
thousand dollars tomorrow once the door
gets fixed and I get my money please
love I'm sorry all these what I can't
remember baba baba once is a settle
nothing will ever hinder us again I miss
you so much Ted uh
then check this out no after sorting out
the bill above sin
is when you have sent the going to bank
earlier please attend it to this quickly
and then it's like all about that I feel
so excited I can't imagine it's like
more of the story then once the bill is
paid then you then you say this and it's
all about thank you for your care and
support I felt your touch so these
people know it's not just about getting
the money and running it's about getting
the money and keeping up the scam how
much can you milk from these people take
all of her money don't take some of
their money take it they want you to
take it then it's exciting for them dude
you're talking about the investment [ __ ]
before right the more they put in the
more excited they are they are they it
is like a little adventure for them
where there's almost this weird like oh
I got swept up you know through three
years of my life gone in like a weird
scam and some of them have kids out of
it like some of them ended like one of
the podcasts I heard very similar this
but he gets some pregnant and [ __ ] -
this is like ya know I don't know how
you could I mean how do you do it it's
so mean dude
it's to make the love and just squeeze
it out of someone stake it hey man when
you get those love letters dude these
guys love letters is next level but but
here's the thing guys you have to be
another level of morally bankrupt to do
this check this out with another victim
who was convinced they were soon to be
married he had her perform in a sexually
explicit manner on skype which he
secretly recorded when she refused to
send more money because she could she
had no more to send he threatened to
post the video online when she could not
come up with more money he sent a link
to her aunt to these videos to her
relatives saying that he had four more
such videos of her and would post them
for the world to see unless the highest
bidder would pay him son mallet old this
woman by the phone that by the time he
would finish with her she would want to
kill herself he pledged to ruin her life
if she did not continue to send him
money she's seriously considered suicide
but survive pole Lee
hey how tight is the money do we need we
got four houses can you leave it got
used to being greedy just stopped at two
houses three houses this is vicious man
it's a power trip at a certain point
yeah ya know and and like a it is
shocking to me
someone like Nityananda followers from
all around the world we got a lot of
love about Nityananda dude the sex tape
is hot you see the site he's a sexy guy
now the younger version of him was in
the sex should we pull up the sex tape
on you you see the sex is free check it
out they by the way guys it's it's all
censored it's not we're not it's very
much censored and they got some good
music oh there is music music they have
really good they're playing stop stop no
no no I don't care let's see what this
is all about so for everyone who doesn't
know hold on let me set this up first of
all as I said before you're not gonna be
shown anything right but this Nityananda
is this holy man from India who said
that among other things he was gonna
remove non-vegetarians from the earth he
was he the Sun stopped right because of
him he disproved Einstein they just
start clapping for him hey there's
something inspirational about that right
he's a man of many chairs he's got some
legendary chairs go watch episode 1 for
that but apparently this is something
that the comment section told us to find
is that he also had a sex tape leaked
about him and that's what he got in
trouble for allegedly or there was also
a rape case that I don't know if that's
this is what we're watching here this
like consensual but he was just getting
down with these ladies let's see let's
see our boy not in a chair and all my
did I just hear Marvin Gaye come on so
from what I understand his driver got
mad at him and set up a secret camera or
someone did yeah somebody does not look
like he's looking at the camera for a
second this is so Brown making the girl
put cream on you and she like that who
would do that I mean he's a call later
he's a call leader so you know they
gotta do that they think see they call
that savor this is she's getting blessed
for this dude don't say he's getting
scammed hey she's getting blessed here's
what you do you he is a spiritual leader
and what not attractive look right now
that's so funny this guy who made this
video replayed the same clip because he
thought it was so funny he could have
done a sex tape dude he could have
planned his own sex tape he's looking at
the camera like several times and he is
a psycho dude he's stealing Scientology
[ __ ] he's stealing Landmark Education I
think he's the kind of psycho that's
like you know what I'm [ __ ] if I want
to pop off as a guru need a sex tape
dude did you hear that they they had to
like forensic Li prove it was him cuz he
kept denying it and like they had to
prove that hey this wasn't a doctored
thing apparently 50 hours of footage got
released hey I don't know this girl was
she was like an actress I think his
defense his defense is oh my gosh this
is amazing
nityananda says that he never had sex
with the woman and he never had sex in
his life because he's a lifelong monk
doesn't defense this is that he's
incapable of having sex on
top of that because he's impotent which
is lies which is yeah we all know that's
why yeah checks what check out number
for checking number for okay the girl
who accused him of this is a promiscuous
woman she's a ho imagine that that's
messed up on the one hand you say okay I
can see if you say I didn't rape her
because she's a ho
but you're saying I never had sex and
she's a ho that's messed up that's rude
that's rude
impotence on yourself don't be negative
and then he says she has contagious
herpes how would he know that anyways
we're going off-track let's let's let's
wrap this up man
thanks for watch and let us know oh we
have a little bit thing to plug real
quick we've got a dedicated email for
tips tricks loves last-gasp if you guys
want to go ahead and hit us up with a
story of how you've been scammed and you
want us to read it live on the Laughing
Baba's podcast go ahead and hit us up at
laughing Baba's at gmail.com that is
laughing Baba's at gmail.com don't get
it twisted I'll leave it in the
description below hit us up hit us up
please give us the stories we want to
talk about them on we need content
people we need cause it would be great
to hear from someone who got it that got
ripped enjoy some emails if you got
ripped and dipped we want an original
email send that email I want to hear it
and frankly we might have you on the
show like actually on the show if you
want to come on call in we gotta call
ins that'd be a lot of fun well guys
we're growing with you
you know we're loving with you guys
we're doing this together yeah thanks
for watching as usual and we will see
you next time thank you so much
but you tell me where to go you can burn
out all the stars in the sea but you
won't ever get your papers on me
you can chain me to your family tree she
won't ever get your papers on me